hey youtubers is Charlie and big news
Marvel just announced that Thor is going
to become a female or they're going to
start a female Thor title so this is
gonna be a breakdown of what's going on
specifically who I think they're gonna
give the hammer to and how I think it's
going to affect the movie universe down
the road real quick hello to any new
people if you're just finding me for the
first time I do Marvel videos every week
be sure to subscribe to get everything
I'm gonna be doing some special
comic-con stuff I'll explain at the end
of this video so right off the bat let's
look at what Marvel actually said this
is just happening in the comics in the
wake of original sin Thor will no longer
be deemed worthy of wielding Mjolnir at
least by the terms of Odin's inscription
so instead of just sitting in a closet
the hammer is going to pass to a new
person and that person will be a female
so what was it that Thor did to lose him
the hammer
during original sin the Thor storyline
revolves around Angela and explaining
why she's the sister of Loki and Thor
and why we just met her this past year
she debuted at the very end of Marvel's
age of Ultron storyline and has been
part of the guardians of the galaxy
ongoing comic if you forgot about the
end of age of Ultron Wolverine
essentially effed up the space-time
continuum and she just randomly appeared
in the galaxy and then just started
running around with the guardians of the
galaxy original sin or at least the Thor
parts of it that ongoing comic is meant
to fill in her backstory her character
used to be part of the spawn comics Neil
Gaiman created her and because of a
bunch of legal rights issues and a
lawsuit that he'd just won he brought
that character to the Angela character
to Marvel and they turned her into an
Asgardian who's the daughter of Odin or
the secret daughter so real quick just
minor spoiler alert for original sin
because I'm gonna talk a little bit
about her backstory and what Thor
possibly does to lose the hammer so all
wait just a sec okay ready here we go
so Angela was supposedly killed during
an ancient Asgardian war with the tenth
realm we've only talked about there
being nine realms in the movie so this
tenth realm was like a brand new thing
in this original sin comic because of
that crime Odin severed the connection
between the tenth realm and the other
nine realms which is why whenever he
talks about the realms he only talks
about the nine realms so in the original
sin comic Loki and Thor traveled to the
tenth realm to learn all about Angela
that hasn't debut yet that won't come
till September so whenever that debuts
we're gonna learn exactly what it is
that he does to Lu
the hammer it's possible that he could
reconnect the tenth realm to the other
nine or do something else really really
terrible he's gonna have to do something
really epic to lose that hammer like
Tony Stark levels of stupidity the new
Thor comic will just be called Thor and
it's gonna debut in October Thor number
one after the original sin Thor
miniseries I think it's an interesting
way to reimagine the title they're not
killing Thor they're just giving the
hammer to someone else there are a few
logic issues here in their statement
they were pretty clear that this would
not be lady Thor or Thor Rita or some
variation on Thor it would be the main
Thor title so technically Thor would
stop being Thor and someone else a
female would take up the mantle they
were not really clear whether or not she
would be calling herself Thor because
Thor is not an alter ego that that's his
name it's like loki is Loki's name it's
not a secret identity I think Marvel is
gonna explain some of these details at
comic-con and what Thor is gonna be
doing when he loses the hammer
presumably trying to make himself worthy
again my overall reaction is just
curiosity obviously I haven't read the
comic yet but I'm always open to new
things in the literature just because
the comics can exist independently of
the movies and the videogames they can
try like really crazy things and if it
pays off it's a huge win but which
character are they gonna give the hammer
to like who is this person gonna be the
most likely candidate is Angela the
whole impetus for a thorolund the hammer
revolves around her so it's the logical
next step of that story but Marvel
released a couple of teaser images and
the female Thor did not have Angela's
ginger complexion that doesn't mean that
it's not Angela but there are a couple
of alternatives
we've met Thor's three daughters when he
travelled to the future last year each
of them embodied aspects of his
personality it could be one of them or
it could be Valkyrie we haven't seen her
in a little while there are a few other
female as Guardians though like Freya
herself she's been all mother in Odin's
absence in the past and then there's
ladies SIF but I don't think it's gonna
be either of them honestly I really do
think it's gonna be Angela and they're
just gonna explain why they're gonna
change her hair color Marvel will
probably keep the secret of who it is
until later this year I don't think
they're gonna flat out say who it is at
Comic Con they're just gonna tease other
details so the real big question is is
how is this going to affect the movie
universe
or is it going to affect the movie
universe now right now and not for the
foreseeable future
Chris Hemsworth is Thor until he serves
out his sixth picture contract and he
could always renew after that's over
he's got two more movies on that right
now which will likely be Thor 3 and
Avengers 3 so if we do see someone new
playing the Thor character on-screen it
won't be till phase 4 or way later
Marvel is really good about hedging
their non robert downey jr bets he's
kind of an exception that's why i think
there's gonna be no Iron Man Ford during
phase 3 they're just gonna wait till
after Avengers 3 and then they're gonna
recast the role but I think in the
comics though if this female recasting
thing with door works then they could
always experiment with it down the road
in the movies but here's why I think
they're probably not gonna do that I
don't think they're gonna make the next
Thor in the movies a female even if they
do recast it I think they'll just make a
female character movie like Black Widow
or Captain Marvel I think that's what
most people are expecting the big
surprise to be at the Marvel comic con
panel they're gonna announce Doctor
Strange they'll announce like a date for
that and they'll announce the mystery
movie is gonna be a black widow movie if
you're not familiar with Marvel's movie
faces right now we're still in phase 2
the phases just comprise large story
arcs that cross over each of the
individual character movies then
culminate in the big Avengers team-up
movies phase 2 Avengers 2 phase 3
Avengers 3 and so on right now guardians
of the galaxy and Avengers two are the
last two movies and phase two after that
ant-man is gonna be the first phase 3
movie so here's a bit of logistics based
on the amount of time they have between
Avengers movies they can really only fit
about 6 movies into each phase unless
they decide to change that they could
always announce something like that at
Comic Con
they're gonna do 7 movies in phase 3
instead of 6 so they already have
several phase 3 movies planned here's
what they have right now ant-man is
gonna be the first phase 3 movie Captain
America 3 for 3 Avengers 3 guardians of
the galaxy - even though that's
technically not confirmed in Doctor
Strange although that is also not
technically confirmed of course it is
totally possible that they could just
announce a date for that Doctor Strange
movie and just completely pass over
black widow news there's plenty of time
between now and whenever production
would have to start on any kind of black
widow movie for them to wait till Comic
Con 2015 to announce a female character
movie but eventually it's going to
happen the reason why I think Black
Widow is going to be the first female
driven movie is because they've already
established the character pretty
significantly and they have ScarJo under
contract it would be a lot easier than
having to establish a whole new
character and having to cast them on a
Captain Marvel so if you're wondering
what a Black Widow movie might look like
it'd be more like a Winter Soldier II
version of a Captain America movie her
just wiping more red off our ledger
dealing with her troubled past but now's
your turn let me know in the comments
below what is your reaction to the
female Thor news and do you think that
they're going to announce a black widow
movie at Comic Con do you think that's
gonna be the big surprise I will
actually be recording that comic-con
panel be sure to subscribe to get all
that stuff I've got a bunch of other
comic-con related stuff that's gonna
happen I'll explain that in a future
bonus video but just recently they
announced that a bunch of footage from
age of Ultron was screened at London so
my next bonus video tonight is actually
gonna be a breakdown of what that is so
you guys get like double Marvel today
you can click here to get that I'll add
the annotation as soon as I post it
tonight and you can click here for my
Ronan the accuser guardians of the
galaxy video thank you so much for
watching
I'll see you guys tonight high fives
you